welcome to another famous friday i
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever obstacles in your way
somebody has already solved it and the
fastest way to solve it yourself
is to model that strategy apply it to
your business
and get to work so today's lesson is the
path of success
is never a straight line and it's by
david ogilvy who's considered the
founder
of modern day advertising now ogilvy
started
on this straight line he went to
university and like most people go to
university you're expected to graduate
you go get an
internship job a trainee you work your
way up the corporate ladder
eventually get to some executive and
then you retire right that's what most
people did
especially in his era you stay with one
company your whole life
but for him it wasn't going to be a
straight line
he flunked out of oxford he went to
oxford university flunked out and
instead of getting back on track getting
back on that straight line he said i'm
going to try
to trust my gut to listen to my heart
and do something that feels right
so he went to paris to learn how to be a
chef
right totally different than what he was
starting but it felt right
and there he studied under a french chef
who was
really who really cared about quality
and who would fire
apprentice chefs who couldn't make their
bread rise and what it instilled in him
was a sense that
this was a winning team and you have to
be ruthless about quality if you want to
build a winning team
he then discovered that you know what
this chef thing it's not for me so i
went back home to england
and he started selling cooking supplies
door-to-door
and he started doing really well he was
making a good income selling cooking
supplies door-to-door
again had nothing to do with what he was
studying everybody would look at him as
a failure
you know he flunked out of university
went to go become a pastry chef
came back started selling things
door-to-door this is what you were
trying to go to university to become
right it didn't make any sense
but he started doing well so well that
the owner of the company the cooking
supply company said david you're doing
really well we'd like you to write a
manual
so that other people can learn how to
sell like you
so we started writing and he found you
know what he loved writing
and then he said you know what i'm going
to leave this cooking job finally
getting some success i'm
leaving my cooking job to try to get a
copywriting job
and he became a copywriter for a company
and that's where he discovered
advertising and when he found it he said
i loved
advertising i devoured it i studied and
read and took it desperately serious
and he went on to become a legend in
advertising he built his own business
he became the guy he was at the top of
his field that all the big companies
wanted to work with
as he built up his reputation because he
loved what he did
so much but that path wasn't that
straight line
right he didn't go to university and
then graduate and take that internship
job and slowly work his way up
that wasn't the path for him and that's
not the path for most successful people
you have to be willing to break the mold
you have to be willing to jump off that
track
take the risk take that strategy that
doesn't make any logical sense but your
heart is telling you to go there
become the french pastry chef go and
sell things door to door
quit a nice paying job to start writing
manuals
right follow what excites you follow
what
is what makes you come alive follow what
you're passionate about and that will
help you get back on track and help you
identify
what that big success path is for you
the path to that success is never the
straight line and if you have the
courage
to jump off you'll eventually find
yourself
and become way more successful than you
would be if you stayed on course so if
that's you right now if you look at an
opportunity and say well
that's too scary or thing i i don't even
know why i'm drawn to that it makes no
logical sense
do it listen to your heart it's the
right thing to do
and believe for those who watching like
the video subscribe to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated
check out the link below to join my
newsletter